le courant passe de nouveau à 95% ce
soir le trafic des trains et des métros
complètement rétabli demain encore des
délestages dans l'avenir une telle panne
risque de se reproduire pourquoi comment
les explications de george buckley
monsieur giscard d'estaing en guinée il
part demain pour une visite de trois
jours les relations franco guinéenne
s'améliore toujours pas de nouvelles
d'alain colas mais un espoir demeure
c'est l'opinion d'alain bombard qui a
été n'offre âgées volontaires mais
monsieur bonsoir la france en panne en
panne d'électricité pendant quatre
bonnes heures et parfois plus vous
l'avez tous vécu vous avez tous quelque
chose à raconter sur têt cette
extraordinaire perturbation qui a gagné
la quasi totalité du territoire français
une partie de la belgique et une partie
de la suisse à 8h27 ce matin seule
l'alsace a été épargné par la panne
doucement très doucement le courant a
été rétabli à partir de midi il est
aujourd'hui rétabli à plus de 95%
il ya eu encore quelques petits
problèmes il ya quelques minutes il y en
aura d'autres demain matin mais ce ne
sera rien en comparaison avec ce qui
s'est passé ce matin les trains bloqués
en rase campagne le métro entre deux
stations les embouteillages bref la
désorganisation la plus complète
tout cela parce qu'un câble
d'alimentation entre la lorraine et la
région parisienne avaient sauté
8h27 ce matin une panne d'électricité
paralyse presque toute la france dans
les grandes villes les rames de métro
s'arrête
les passagers évacués les stations à
paris on ferme les grilles de la ratp
les feux tricolores ne fonctionne plus
et d'importants embouteillages blanc pur
bloquent le centre des villes de
nombreuses personnes restent coincées
dans les ascenseurs nécessitant pour les
dégager l'intervention des pompiers les
chauffage ne fonctionne plus à ussel un
chirurgien d'hermine une opération avec
une lampe de poche
cette panne géante est la plus longue
qu'ait jamais connu la france seule la
région du nord a été épargnée grâce aux
courants en provenance d'allemagne
les usagers peuvent se dire que si l'on
n'a pas de pétrole et plus d'électricité
il reste encore la possibilité d'avoir
des idées ou en fait je le répète c'est
plutôt l'est que le nord qui est épargné
pige ajoute même que leurs limites de
validation du loto a été retardée de
deux bonnes heures en raison de la panne
pour en revenir maintenant à l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire à l'explication de ces
gigantesques perturbations il ya d'abord
cette carte c'est là que tout s'est
passé c'est là qu'un câble qui relie la
lorraine à la région parisienne a cessé
de fonctionner et à partir de là tout
s'est écroulé comme un château de cartes
le réseau d'interconnexion n'a pas suffi
ceci malgré les prévisions de l'edf qui
avait dans ses statistiques annoncées
pour demain
8h30 la plus forte consommation
d'électricité pour l'année
il paraît que c'est toujours le cas pour
le troisième mercredi 2 décembre mais la
l'edf a été prise de court la
consommation était trop forte
c'est un incident quand même assez
exceptionnel
vous savez qu'il fait froid ce matin il
a fait plus froid mais enfin il fait
froid ce matin notre part l'hydraulicité
bavette que nos barrages des beats peu
le résultat c'est que nous étions
vraiment tout près de nous limite avec
une marge relativement faible mais le
problème c'est que notre réseau
actuellement relativement fragile
d'une part parce que si nous sommes
capables de passer en moyenne production
nous sommes relativement libre
it et d'autre part parce qu'il ya un
profond déséquilibre actuel entre l'est
de la france qui est relativement riche
en production par rapport à sa
consommation et le west et autres frères
faible alors dans les situations tendues
le réseau est très fragile parce qu'il
est en quelque sorte déséquilibré du
côté de l'ouest où on importe énormément
donc on peut craindre de nouvelles
coupures et bien ce qui est exact c'est
que du fait que la france comme beaucoup
de pays européens traversent une crise
économique
il est de ce fait beaucoup plus
difficile de trouver des financement
pour investir est donc naturel que
toutes les branches d'activité compris
là d'autres prennent plus de risques ce
qui est vrai c'est que pour le passage
des proches à l'hiver nous prenons plus
de risques que d'habitude alors pour
bien comprendre les explications
officielles et il faut essayer georges
leclercq de décortiquer un petit peu la
façon dont le courant et distribue
instruit alors la panne s'est produite
ici rupture d'un câble de 400 kilovolts
quatre cent mille vols
si on fait du couvent qui est produit en
excédent dans la région s qui produit
plus que ne consomme qui est distribué
par exemple dans la région ouest au
moment où elle consomme plus qu'elle ne
produit était le cas ce matin c'était le
cas ce matin c'est un réseau win nous
avons représenté le réseau de 400
kilovolts ici il fait l'équivalent de
deux fois le tour de la terre alors il
faut dire aussi gai des connexions avec
l'étranger ce cela et distribution de
courant les heures de pointe ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes en france et à
l'étranger on peut donc à certains
moments acheter du courant d'étrangers
pour faire face à nos besoins et au
contraire à d'autres moments en revanche
c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'allemagne finalement a pu alimenter
une part de l'alsace alors cette femme
pourquoi c'était le produite
eh bien on n'en sait rien aujourd'hui et
monsieur giraud le ministre de
l'industrie viennent désigner une
mission d' enquête formaient de deux
ingénieurs généraux alors ce que
j'aurais quand même vous dire c'est que
pourquoi cette valve est ce que la
france n'a pas assez de pylônes pas à
cette centrale pour faire face à la
demande à une demande comme celle de ce
matin n'est qu'un petit pépin un
problème alors est ce qu'il faudrait par
exemple construire davantage de
centrales davantage de philo ou au
contraire baisser notre consommation
éviter de faire trop de tout électrique
à éviter d'avoir des consommateurs
d'énergie énorme dans notre appartement
dans notre maison
les gros appareils électroménagers voyez
c'est un peu
le problème qui se pose actuellement
hier c'était le pétrole aujourd'hui
électricité l'énergie quotidienne est
difficile à manier
l'approvisionnement est difficile dans
ne prévoit pas très bien aux besoins
peut-être le moment d'ailleurs de passer
aux énergies un peu humaine qu'on
pourrait utiliser nous-mêmes et
maîtrisée nous mêmes les économies
d'énergie qu'on fait chez nous l'énergie
solaire con pour l installer chacun chez
soi
en attendant si ce soir il n'y a pas
d'autres coupures d'électricité l'edf
aura réussi quand même quelque chose de
très grand beaucoup mieux que les
américains lors des pannes de new york
en 65 à 77 maîtriser l'ensemble de ce
réseau ça c'est quand même pas mal oui
saviez pas besoin de vous dire que l'edf
a été submergée de protestations d'usagé
ou d'associations nombreux ceux qui
parlent d'un prévisions il ya parfois
des contradictions dans la critique par
exemple la cgc estime que la panne est
le résultat des manifestations un sens
et d'écologistes inconscients qui ont
retardé de plusieurs années le programme
d'équipements électriques et puis les
écologistes des amis de la terre
répondent eux que c'est la politique de
l'edf irresponsable de la coupure
la cfdt souhaite la mise en place d'une
commission denquête l'union fédérale des
consommateurs l'appui et puis la cgt
estime qu'on aurait dû d'écouté depuis
bien longtemps
cet incident est effectivement
prévisibles compte tenu de
l'insuffisance des moyens de production
et transport insuffisant ce que nous
soulignons pour notre part depuis 1976
et par conséquent il peut se reproduire
certes et je l'espère dans
- dans grande gravité mais des
délestages auront lieu sans doute dans
la soirée en lieu peuvent avoir lieu
dans les jours suivants compte tenu en
fonction de la température il n'y a pas
de parade si ce genre d'incident se
produit on peut considérer que
l'économie du pays peut être paralysé le
temps que durent les vannes à ce qu'il
ya et ce que j'espère c'est que les
prochains délestage ce rond point
important et n'affecteront pas la
totalité du pays comme ce matin est ce
que cet incident risque de remettre en
cause votre action pour jeudi prochain
vient nous avons décidé compte tenu de
cette situation nouvelle de demander à
nos camarades de la production thermique
et de la production hydraulique de ne
pas baisser la production jeudi
ceci dit ils participeront avec la même
volonté à l'arrêt de travail de deux
heures minimum et participons à toutes
les manifestations aux côtés des autres
travailleurs du pays
je retiens donc la cgtr fait un geste en
décidant de ne pas couper l'électricité
jeudi malgré la consigne lancé
précédemment dans le cadre de la journée
d'action donc du 21
une coupure qui a également provoqué
quelques motion à l'assemblée le
communiste robert ballanger a par
exemple demandé aux ministres andré
giraud de venir s'expliquer le ministre
répondra demain dans le cadre des
questions d'actualité l'assemblée doux
daniel braid m'a téléphoné tout à
l'heure pour me parler d'un retour à la
sérénité au sein de la majorité après la
lettre que jacques chirac a adressé ce
matin raymond barre lettre dans laquelle
le rpr s'engage à ne pas prendre
l'initiative de remettre en cause
l'existence du gouvernement tout en
renouvelant son appréhension l'égard de
la politique européenne du chef de
l'état commentaire d'un député gaulliste
on est descendu des barricades bref il
semble que l'on puisse parler ce soir de
désescalade
les sénateurs pendant ce temps refusé
d'examiner à lattes le projet de loi sur
l'aide des l'aide aux travailleurs
privés d'un poids ils ne le feront qu'à
partir du 3 janvier accord à bruxelles
aujourd'hui sur le vin entre les
ministres de la culture des neuf voilà
plusieurs années que l'italie la france
heurter à leur partenaire ils ont donc
obtenu en partie satisfaction
un accord qui tient en trois points
premier point un prix minimum du vin
payés à tous les viticulteurs de la
communauté a été instauré aujourd'hui à
bruxelles
et en cas de crise il est désormais
interdit de commercialiser des vins de
table en dessous de ce prix deuxième
point les viticulteurs italiens pourront
être imposées de distiller jusqu'à 12%
de leurs excédents
cela permettra d'équilibrer les prix
entre l'italie et la france
enfin troisième point l'aide à
l'utilisation des moûts concentrés pour
augmenter le taux d'alcool des vins va
être étendu à tous les pays de la
communauté mais toujours pas
d'autorisation de sucre âge du moins
pour les viticulteurs du midi de la
france
ces mesures qui entreront en vigueur
pour les prochaines vendanges ne devrait
pas avoir de conséquences importantes
sur les prix à la consommation
mais par contre elle pourrait améliorer
nettement la qualité des vins du moins
pour certaines régions au conseil des
ministres ce matin trois décisions la
fixation de la date des prochaines
élections cantonales ce sera les 18 et
25 mars
et conséquence de la hausse du prix du
pétrole elle ne se répercutera qu'à
moitié sur l'essence nous vous l'avons
dit hier et enfin l'adoption d'un projet
de loi sur les collectivités locales
davantage de moyens pour les
municipalités un traitement pour les
maires des grandes villes et d'une façon
générale plus de pouvoir pour les mères
et puis l'établissement d'une nouvelle
procédure le référendum communal
cette procédure du référendum ne pourra
être déclenché que par le maire de la
commune avec l'accord des deux tiers de
son conseil municipal
l'objet du référendum doit être de la
compétence communale par exemple tracé
des routes implantation d'une école
urbanisme ce sera un vrai référendum
respectant les conditions du code
électoral son résultat s'imposera comme
une décision du conseil municipal dès
lors que la majorité des gages et
représentera au moins un quart des
électeurs inscrits son sens politique et
d'intéresser les français leur vie
quotidienne répondre à leur besoin de
s'exprimer directement cette procédure
du référendum sans doute l'aspect le
plus spectaculaire du projet de loi sur
les collectivités locales sera discutée
à l'assemblée ainsi que l'ensemble du
projet au printemps prochain les
affaires sociales maintenant avec ce et
interio d'edmond maire dans le journal
libération qui sortira demain les
risques d'une déstabilisation générale
de la société sont évidents estime le
secrétaire général de la cfdt
sur le terrain alors que le conseil des
ministres des neuf à bruxelles a
reconduit pour un an le plan anti crise
dans la sidérurgie et bien le
valenciennois se préparent à une journée
nationale de protestation demain et la
ville de longwy en lorraine sort d'une
journée ville morte des rues désertes et
des commerces fermés des écoles vide des
cinémas à 100 spectateurs
c'était bien le visage d'une ville mort
que ferait aujourd'hui l'ong oui à
chaque entrée de la ville des barrages
coupaient la circulation et les
manifestants se réchauffer sur des
brasero de fortune
c'était bien sûr pour protester contre
les 5500 licenciements annoncés la
semaine dernière par usinor qu'à l'appel
de tous les syndicats la population du
bassin à cesser le travail pour 24
heures car les sidérurgistes ne sont pas
les seuls touchés on estime aussi que
près d'un commerce sur 10 devra bientôt
fermés dans l'après midi un cortège de
15 à 20 mille manifestants s'est rendu
devant les portes du zune à la
manifestation s'est déroulée dans le
calme
et puis une autre manifestation
aujourd'hui à paris celle d'un certain
nombre de pompiers professionnels qui
répondait là à l'appel de la cgt de la
cfdt et de la cftc
les syndicats réclament la création de
30000 emplois nouveaux
il faut dire que dans certaines villes
celles d'arras par exemple la situation
n'est pas loin d'atteindre le seuil
critique pour un enfant devenir pompier
c'est un rêve qui remonte au moins à
napoléon s'est en effet l' empire qui a
créé ce corps d'élite
le centre de secours d'arras est
intervenue plus de 900 fois depuis le
début de l'année des interventions qui
vont des opérations de plongée aux
dégâts de tempête en passant par les
sauvetages d'animaux les incendies
viennent en tête suivi par les accidents
de la route
avec comme ici la désincarcération d'un
blessé prisonnier des tôles
mais bon
allez on
dix minutes après l'appel aux secours le
blessé grave est amené au centre
hospitalier accompagné d'une assistance
médicale vingt minutes plus tard
la route sera rendue à la circulation la
complémentarité entre pompiers médecins
et policiers est évidente ici au même
titre qu'une compétence sans faille
je crois que la 110 l accident ou s'il
particulier qu'ils ne passent pas les
erreurs je pense d'ailleurs que les
sapeurs pompiers qu'ils soient
professionnels volontaires considère la
fonction de sa part confié d'ailleurs
plus de plus comme pratiquement une
mission que d'un métier en fournit une
heure par jour est consacré à
l'enseignement théorique étude de plans
de secteur ou d'autoroutes mais aussi
des cours de chimie ou sur les matériaux
nouveaux
le pompier est un spécialiste le
matériel est efficace grâce à un
entretien rigoureux mais les effectifs
sont insuffisants
comment voulez vous que nous ne soyons
pas inquiets ici à arras par exemple
quand nous avons plus de cent vingt
mille habitants à défendre répartis en
80 une commune un effectif du coeur
réduit à neuf sapeurs pompiers
professionnels par jour pour défendre
cette population nous sommes
parfaitement conscients que ça qu'un
jour qu'à certains moments il ya des
risques pour la population et que ces
risques nous voulons les dénoncer pour
le district urbain arras et 80 une autre
commune soit 110 mille habitants il y as
par roulement de 24 heures deux hommes
pour répondre aux appels et sept prêts à
intervenir
et
les textes préconise le rapport d'un
pompier professionnel pour 15 cents
habitants au centre d'arras
il en faudrait donc 73 ils sont 29 au
total
côté pouvoirs publics on estime que des
améliorations sont possibles mais on
insiste sur leur coût financier et on
attend des décisions ministérielles
c'est dans ce sens que la plupart des
pompiers seront à paris pour la journée
d'action nationale
pas touche 9 resteront sur place pour
assurer leurs missions
et précisément aujourd'hui qu'ils ont eu
fort à faire à l'étranger maintenant
d'abord l'arrestation il ya quelques
heures de madame gandhi qui pourtant
avait été réélu député il ya quelques
mois et qui l'année dernière avait déjà
passé quelques jours en prison pour
proches toujours à l'ancien premier
ministre indien des abus de privilèges
et puis l'iran l'iran qui après les
manifestations de la semaine dernière
semble entrer dans une phase plus
politique le roi poursuit ses
consultations dans l'espoir de former un
gouvernement civil mais rabbit si la
population est sorti de sa léthargie et
elle aura du mal à oublier le père le
passé c'est par exemple la savak la
police politique iranienne l'a arrêté
est la torture est là on savait mais ce
soir antenne 2 grâce à bernard benyamin
et daniel mailhot est en mesure de vous
apporter son témoignage elle a recueilli
de la bouche d'un homme qui viennent de
sortir de prison il ya trois mois qui a
été torturé pendant trois à 30 ans 3 ans
et qui vous allez l'entendre est encore
visiblement sous le choc
il s'exprime très lentement ses premiers
mots sont pour expliquer ce qui s'est
passé quand il est arrivé au comité le
comité ad dire une prison de sinistre
réputation à terre
dix minutes après mon arrivée à comité
j'ai été amenée tanguant chambre de
torture et dès lors je suis passé 14
jours sous la torture flageul mans avec
ses différents sortes câbles des chocs
électriques être suspendue or les mânes
être réveillé des nuits entières avec
les mains attachées à montaut être
brûlés avec des câbles électriques
restent ténus au foie la rate et humide
en au pouvoir jusque ce flottement entre
le haut
apollo c'est une machine à torture qui
soumet tous les corps le corps la tête
compris sous une intense pression les 10
tours tours étaient infligés tous les
jours et plusieurs voies jusqu'à
évanouissement
après quatorze jours j'étais emmené à
l'hôpital
le deuxième fois j'ai subi la torture
pour vêture j'étais encore à l'hôpital
pour pouvoir supporter la troisième et à
de la torture qui était à recevoir une
portion de la jument pour fusion jour en
même temps des cons sur la tête et pieds
et sur les blessures et est exercée
régulièrement maintenant après trois ans
je souffre encore de douleurs dans mon
corps voilà bien que notre caméraman
daniel mailhot est en partie masqué le
visage de cet homme je n'ai pas besoin
de vous dire qu'il a pris des risques
quand même début demain de la visite de
valéry giscard d'estaing en guinée un
voyage qui durera trois jours et qui
marque le net réchauffement des
relations entre la france et la toute
jeune république de monsieur sékou touré
elle a tout juste de vaincre un survol
maintenant de ce pays situé à la pointe
extrême ouest de l'afrique avec le
premier reportage de michel meyer
le dernier président français accueillis
dans ce stade de conakry a été charles
de gaulle depuis les fêtes et cérémonies
nationales de la guinée du président
sékou touré ont eu le temps d'accentuer
leur allure de rassemblement populaire à
la mode de l'est
l'affluence de l'urss et de ses
satellites d'europe de l'est est en
effet sensible sur les rituels de la vie
politique intérieure et sur les
structures du pouvoir dans le pays
cette influence se perçoit jusque dans
la mise en scène à la cubaine des
défilés et spectacles militaire d'un
état qui se veut socialiste mais qui est
surtout très soucieux de son
indépendance
petite révolution
andrew yang l'ambassadeur à l'onu du
président carter étaient venus applaudir
les exploits des jeux de la dépendance
en fait la présence d'un émissaire du
président américain à conakry n'a plus
rien de paradoxal
cela malgré le ton des discours du
congrès du parti unique guinéen le
président sékou touré continue de
fustiger le colonialisme et
l'impérialisme mais ils ne pensent plus
uniquement aux occidentaux
en prononçant ses light motifs africains
les diplomates des pays de l'est ne
citerons point la guinée s'ouvre à
l'ouest de façon spectaculaire
l'ambassadeur soviétique offre certes
une statut de héros du socialisme aux
frères guinéens
il ne peut cependant ignorer un
changement radical de climat depuis le
début des années 60 l'union soviétique
occupe une place de choix dans la vie
économique de la guinée
le bilan de cette coopération est
cependant décevant
à une centaine de kilomètres de conakry
les russes exploite notamment la
principale mine de bauxite du pays les
soviétiques ont équipé cette mine à
leurs frais contre la livraison de 90
pour cent du minerai extrait les 10%
restants étant vendu à l'urss à des
cours très inférieur aux cours mondiaux
pour les guinéens qui ont très
péniblement obtenu des augmentations de
prix
ce marché est un marché de dupes ils
sont déçus et se sentent exploitées
économiquement dans le port de conakry
ce sont toujours des bateaux soviétique
qui sont à quai pour charger les
minerais guinéens pourtant à l'intérieur
du pays
ce sont des sociétés de prospection
minière française et américaine qui de
plus en plus prennent le relais des
russes cette réorientation très claire
des termes de la politique de
coopération économique de la guinée est
profonde
il s'agit là d'une démarche délibérée du
président sékou touré nous voulons faire
une couverture lâche enfin faire loyal
pour en vue d'une coopération sincère et
durable avec tous ceux qui veulent côté
avec nous sur la base de l'égalité du
respect des institutions des
personnalités et des intérêts mis en
cause la technique n'est ni socialiste
ni capitaliste
la technologie n'est ni socialiste ni
capitaliste les connaissances les savoir
faire et les échanges les marchandises
que nous échangeons n'appartiennent à
aucune couleur philosophique mais nous
pouvons malgré les différences de choix
idéologiques mettre en commun librement
les moyens travailler à la réalisation
d'une même action rentable profitable
aux éléments associés et couture est que
valéry giscard d'estaing rencontrera
demain donc en guinée remise en liberté
de l'internet de creil c'était une
audience médecine avait été inculpé de
violence et de non assistance en
personne en danger pour avoir refusé
l'hospitalier sur d'un malade est mort
quatre jours après pas de crise de foi
cette année pour le maire de paris et
ses adjoints privé de chocolat par un
voleur astucieux pour ses commandes de
noël la ville de paris avait choisi une
fabrique pyrénéenne
ce fut une info transporteurs qui
s'empara de la commande d'environ 11
tonnes prix du but
quatre cent mille francs la nasa à
tourner une page de l'histoire de
l'espace en renonçant à sauver le skylab
depuis quelques mois elle n'avait perdu
le contrôle le contrôle d'un mastodonte
de 80,6 tonnes
la nasa attendra donc que scalabre tombe
sur terre ou espérons le se désintègre
entre mai et septembre prochain skylab
c'est un énorme engin spatial de 85
tonnes lancé en 1973 par la nasa
américaine
il comprend un gros télescopes des
laboratoires et un compartiment
d'habitation pour un équipage de trois
hommes trois équipe d'astronautes
américains sont venus l'occupé jusqu'en
février 74 depuis le skylab est vide
livré aux forces de la nature
la nasa lui avait prévu une durée de vie
d'environ 10 ans en orbite terrestre
mais très vite dès l'année dernière le
lourd engin commence à ce déséquilibre
et a basculé sur son orbite et à se
rapprocher dangereusement de la terre
parmi les causes n'ont prévu le vent
solaire qui vient balayer la terre et
accentue les frottements de la haute
atmosphère sur le sky la nasa alors
lancé un programme pour y placer des
moteurs grâce à la navette spatiale
moteur qu'il entraînerait plus haut mais
l'argent manque
la navette est difficile à mettre au
point et risque d'arriver trop tard
alors la nasa abandonne condamne ce cas
là bas la chute
quelque part sur la terre dans un an un
an et demi
n'importe où entre le 50e parallèle donc
sur la france les usa la chine ou côté
des espérons le
en mer jean piat 60 socata d'état à la
jeunesse aux sports a parlé du sport à
l'école cet après midi parmi ces
propositions la création de 400 nouveaux
postes de titulaires 462 joie et la
titularisation de 313 me remets toujours
autant d'heures supplémentaires pour les
profs d'éducation physique pour
s'occuper des enfants sur les stades les
propositions qui n'attirent pas
l'entousiasme du syndicat national de
l'éducation physique c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
maintenant vous parler d'un homme que la
presse est un petit peu l'opinion sont
doucement en train d'oublier
alors que tout espoir n'est pas perdu
alain colas 35 jours de silence et rien
de nouveau c'est par exemple le
sentiment d' hannah bombard qui sait de
quoi il parle pour le naufragé solitaire
il y à un quart de siècle le problème
des recherches de doit pas concerner
uniquement la marine nationale
je ne crois qu'il est souhaitable que
des garçons comme colas comme kersauson
comme my love ski et les moins connus
sorte de cette civilisation maternelle
et prennent des risques et je trouve ça
merveilleux
ils mettent leur vie dans la balance
c'est merveilleux c'est sensationnel
ensuite il ya le problème de la course
alors là il ya un problème des
organisateurs il est impossible de bien
surveiller une telle course est pas
possible
les routes sont variés on voit rien
depuis un avion quand un bateau est en
perdition si la mère remue un peu mais
ceux qui partent le savent et ils ont
couru les risques mais si on fait des
recherches et on doit le faire et bien
comme c'était une opération publicitaire
j'estime que ça n'est pas la
collectivité qui doit payer ses
recherches mais que ce sont ceux qui
auraient gagné de l'argent grâce à cette
publicité
voilà je suis absolument formel il y
avait des sociétés qui ont les sponsors
dont vous parlez eh ben c'est eux qui
devraient payer les recherches ou même
lorsque vous êtes parti de villefranche
sur mer avec leur éthique
je suis parti à monaco j'avais rempli un
papier disant que je demandais je ne me
cherche pas je déchargeais la marine de
toute responsabilité que je courais mon
risque est que je le courrai seul à
votre sens ce qu'elle a pu survivre si
par bonheur il est à bord de sa survie
ou encore sur la coque de menus rêve est
bien ainsi que la est à bord d'un
pneumatique qui peut survivre avec tout
de même une
question dans quel état et son pied
c'est à dire qu'il ya un problème de
maladie c'est un homme qui n'est tout de
même pas un homme entièrement bien
portants mais alors je crois vraiment
que l'énergie de colas en intelligence
de la mer sa connaissance de la mer font
que s'il est en vie sur un radeau
pneumatique
je pense qu'on peut le retrouver voilà
j'ai quelques secondes vous pour vous
parler de la météo la france a grelotté
aujourd'hui moins 4 à -6 à peu partout
mais dans l'ensemble beau temps sec pour
demain temps froid avec gelée nocturne
allant jusqu'à -8 sur l'ajout du nord a